the movie is based in the near future a
massive asteroid is advancing towards
Earth and threatening to wipe out
Humanity therefore the International
Community has come together for an
operation called the UN Ms which is
spearheaded by the Chinese government it
intends to launch a group of
supernuclear missiles from a large base
on the lunar surface the plan is to use
these missiles to shatter the asteroid
and use the moon to Shield the remaining
debris from hitting Earth after eight
years of meticulous planning the
missiles are launched and the massive
asteroid is successfully destroyed this
sends everyone on earth into a state of
frenzy yes we didn't even have to
sacrifice Tommy Lee Jones meanwhile on
the moon the Project's maintenance
engineer dugu UA welcomes the project
Commander Shing back to the lunar base
after she returns from launching the
nuclear missiles it becomes clear that
UA has a major crush on his Commander
but the latter reprimands him for being
lazy and sends him back to his room lo
and behold it's then revealed that one
of the nuclear missiles was thrown off
course by a solar storm form leaving
some of the asteroid fragments heading
towards the unms moon station Commander
Shing immediately alerts everyone at the
base and orders them to rush to the
evacuation Rockets however UA is lost in
his thoughts oblivious to the threat
looming outside and people say simping
isn't Dangerous by the time he notices
the warnings and comes to his senses he
learns that all Rockets but one have
already left the lunar surface the last
rocket is piloted by Shang and UA rushes
towards her in his space rover but
unfortunately along the way he crashes
into a gigantic hole and Shing is forced
to take off leaving him behind after a
while UA climbs back to the surface and
watches the rocket leaving at the same
time the asteroids rain down on the
lunar surface destroying everything in
their way fearing for his life UA rushes
towards a nearby crater for shelter
however the impact from an asteroid
throws him like a ragdoll knocking him
unconscious unbeknownst to him another
massive asteroid flies over the moon on
its way to the Earth UA eventually gains
Consciousness and as he begins to cuss
out his teammates for leaving him behind
he finally notices the large asteroid on
a collision course with Earth soon a
gigantic explosion occurs annihilating a
large portion of the Earth's surface
distraught UA immediately rushes back to
the lunar base and tries to call for
help however all his attempts to contact
humans are met with silence several days
passed by and it soon Dawns on UA that
there's a possibility of him being the
only human alive in this universe he
goes into Despair and starts honoring
his Fallen friends the only good thing
is that he has enough food to last at
least 80 years one day he decides to go
to his Crush slash Commander shing's
room the loneliness drives him mad and
he sets up a date with a DIY figure of
Shang after the meal he makes out with
the figure something tells me he's done
this before meanwhile it's revealed that
some humans have managed to survive the
asteroid and UA's teammates including
Commander Shang have safely made it back
to Earth somewhere in underground base
commander Shing and the others awkwardly
watch UAE go mad and make out with her
picture they feel embarrassed by his
actions but the Project's chairman feels
that they should establish contact with
UA he wants to broadcast the story of
UA's survival to everyone alive on Earth
because the ratings on this reality TV
show will break all kinds of Records uh
I mean so that they can get a glimmer of
hope and combat the terrible living
conditions that they're currently facing
however the only problem is that the
asteroid strike has destroyed the
communication link between UA and the
base on Earth back at the lunar base UA
notices a ripped food package on the
floor he has taken aback as he doesn't
recall opening it maybe it was the fake
woman that you keep making out with
suddenly UA Hears A noise coming from
storage and when he reaches there he
notices a curvy female Shadow this makes
you a hopeful again and he starts
dreaming of repopulating the earth he
even starts flirting with the shadow
which he thinks is of a woman however to
his astonishment UA learns that it's a
giant kangaroo named Kong eating away
this stored food yep UA's lost his [ __ ]
it turns out that the animal was brought
to the lunar base for research purposes
UA quickly picks up a shovel and tries
to scare the animal away from the
storeroom but unfortunately this only
agitates the kangaroo and it beats the
life out of him unable to beat it with
physical Force UA dresses up as a female
kangaroo and tries to seduce Kong the
trick works for a while but it soon
backfires on UA when the kangaroo gets
excited and tries to have coitus with
him surely yuei was expecting this and
is quite excited in the process Kong
knocks off UA's costume exposing him
this infuriates the kangaroo even more
and it kicks you a across the room as
everyone on Earth watches an
astonishment a stubborn UA pulls out his
Gatling gun and indiscriminately fires a
Kong with plastic balls Kong appears to
retreat but after a while it comes back
and pounds you a continuously after
hours of back and forth the fight comes
to an end when they both knock each
other out on the ground as yuei picks
himself up off the ground he notices
that the communication of devices
receiving signals from Earth this again
lights a glimmer of hope in UA that
maybe Humanity has survived however
unbeknownst to him it's revealed that
the signal was caused by the kangaroo's
tail after regaining the will to return
home UA emotionally tells Kong that they
might have a chance to return home again
however the kangaroo ruins the moment
and punches him again 200 days have
passed by since the incident and now UA
has learned to co-exist with the
kangaroo he has also conjured up an
escape plan to Earth he wants to utilize
the spacecraft left behind by Mission
Apollo 18 to launch himself to a nearby
space station and use its Escape pods to
return back to Earth one day UA sets out
to retrieve the spacecraft with Kong the
two eventually managed to bring it back
into the base but UA realizes that the
rocket can only carry a weight of 20
pounds the problem can only be solved if
he can find a different propulsion
system luckily the prototype for a
nuclear weapon is still on the moon so
UA decides to go and retrieve it after
gearing up with the necessary Essentials
UA immediately Ventures out with long to
retrieve the nuclear rocket he is aware
that the journey may take weeks as the
research building housing the rocket is
located on the other side of the moon
back on Earth Commander Shing and the
others watch them anxiously because UA's
vehicle is solely solar powered and the
sun only Shines on the moon's surface
for 14 days per lunar cycle this means
that the car can only travel 6 500
kilometers but the research building is
situated 8 000 kilometers away from UA's
base after the sun sets on the moon UA
is going to be stranded in the middle of
nowhere and freeze to death just when
all hope seems to be lost Shing and the
others notice that UA is actually headed
in the opposite direction it turns out
he is planning to chase the sunlight as
the moon only rotates at 16 kilometers
per hour this gives UA exactly 41 days
to complete his mission where he can
only sleep for four hours a day with the
days passing by he becomes very dreary
and even starts hallucinating
fortunately Kong is there to motivate
him to keep going and there's no shot
that he's going to hallucinate anything
weirder than that after a long and
perilous Journey the two finally arrive
at the research facility inside UA finds
the nuclear warhead and carefully lowers
It To The Ground however the kangaroo
starts playing with the control buttons
endangering the mission and sending UA
into panic mode on his way back to the
home base with the Warhead UA lox Kong
inside his trunk to stop him from
jeopardizing the mission again it's a
long and rough Journey so UA plays a
loud music to keep himself entertained
as a result he doesn't notice when the
trunk carrying the kangaroo separates
from the vehicle after traveling
hundreds of kilometers UA finally
realizes that Kong has been left behind
because of his mistake now UA is faced
with a difficult decision if he goes
back to get Kong he will lose the
sunlight and the vehicle will stop
working but if he doesn't go Kong will
freeze to death either my imaginary
kangaroo friend dies or we both die hmm
it's a no-brainer UA contemplates for a
bit and eventually decides to go head
back and retrieve the kangaroo putting
his own life in danger after hours of
traveling in the opposite direction he
makes it to the track and reunites with
his friend the two share an emotional
moment and just like a puppy Kong likes
him out of excitement the two then set
out on their Journey towards the base
while trying not to fall asleep as the
sun continues to move farther away from
their vehicle unfortunately even after
their best efforts the sun eludes the
two making it impossible for them to
survive hey at least UA got licked by a
kangaroo on the moon despite this UA
refuses to give up and he continues to
drive the vehicle as it is forced into
its last hours of battery he also turns
off the heat to conserve as much energy
as possible eventually the car runs out
of battery and it comes to a halt 55
kilometers away from their base now the
duo only has three hours of oxygen left
and UA finally gives up he emerges from
the vehicle and awaits his death however
an idea suddenly strikes him when he
notices that his animal friend is
attracted to the Reflection from his
mirror he quickly pulls at the door of
his vehicle and transforms it into a
sled which will be powered by Kong
oh sweet I thought he was gonna murder
Kong and live inside of his skin UA then
flashes light beams in front of the
kangaroo to make him chase them the
trick works and he starts sliding across
the moon's surface like Santa Claus
after a while the two come across a
giant pit but UA again refuses to give
up and instructs Kong to jump over it as
they fly over the giant hole he
unleashes the gas tank on his back which
gives them enough thrust required to
make it to the other side and eventually
to the base Checkmate Vin Diesel back on
Earth the Project's chairman broadcasts
UA's Journey to the remaining humans and
it gives them courage and hope for
Humanity's survival it also earns him a
crap ton of AD revenue on Twitch on the
moon UA eventually brings back the giant
Warhead and prepares for his return to
Earth unbeknownst to him it's revealed
that a second asteroid is headed towards
Earth later UA receives another signal
and becomes hopeful that the surviving
humans on Earth are trying to contact
him unfortunately his happiness soon
turns into disappointment when he sees
that it is actually coming because the
kangaroo is messing with the wires hence
UA again loses hope and decides to abort
his mission however the people back on
Earth refuse to let him give up and
think of an idea to contact him all of
them gather at one particular place and
collectively shine their flashlights
towards the moon UA eventually notices
the signal and is moved to tears
realizing that he is not the only human
alive later with reinvigorated
motivation he realigns the receivers and
is finally able to contact the humans on
Earth including his Crush Commander
Shang in a private moment UA confesses
to Shang that she was the sole reason
for him to come on the unms mission
Shing is moved by his confession and she
apologizes for leaving him behind in the
next scene UA with the help of his
teammates back on Earth starts modifying
the propulsion system of the rocket
using the atomic weapon so it can take
him back home after completing the setup
UA and Kong embark on their journey and
safely enter the orbit unaware that a
second asteroid is heading directly for
Earth while the humans back home
celebrate UA reaches the lunar space
station as he prepares to enter the
Escape pods Commander Shang finally
learns about the asteroid that is
threatening to annihilate the planet
Earth the unms HQ then realizes that
only UA can save Humanity as he is in
possession of the nuclear weapon on
board the lunar space station left with
no choice Shing breaks the news to UA
and surprisingly he agrees to sacrifice
himself to save Humanity finally there
is a point to simping after all
following this unms orders everyone back
on Earth to return to their shelters and
prepare for the worst meanwhile in space
UA tearfully bids goodbye to Kong and
sends him back to Earth in an escape pod
why didn't he take the Escape pod and
shoot the goddamn kangaroo at the thing
UA is an emotional wreck but he collects
himself as he has been tasked to save
Humanity after a while UA heads towards
the asteroid and enters a cluster of
giant rocks he tries his best to avoid
them but his surroundings become more
crowded and chaotic Iraq eventually
collides with his ship causing the
vessel to spin violently in space UA
scrambles to stabilize the ship that's
completely out of control eventually he
comes up with a solution he breaks open
the door of the ship and uses it to
equalize the pressure finally bringing
the rotation to a halt UA then checks on
the ship's engine only to learn that it
has been completely destroyed and can no
longer lead him to the asteroid left
with no other choice he decides to
manually take the nuclear bomb to the
giant asteroid this means that UA dies
an extremely painful death however
without a second thought he Ventures out
and unlocks the Warhead then he uses his
jet pack to head straight towards the
massive asteroid while dragging the
nuclear warhead with him UA's spacesuit
is slowly destroyed by the countless
rocks but he finally reaches the
asteroid in his last moment he remembers
his Crush Commander Shang before a huge
explosion takes place and the asteroid
is blown into Smithereens back on Earth
people finally emerge from their
shelters and notice the giant explosion
in the sky they are elated to have
survived the apocalypse but are also sad
that UA has sacrificed himself several
years passed by and the humans have
restored Earth to its former glory the
kangaroo Kong is returned back to its
natural habitat while Commander Shang
and her team are again sent back to the
moon so they can continue their work of
protecting the Earth from
extraterrestrial threats I was kinda
hoping Kong would end up with Shang
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching